there's a bit of a mix of cultures in
your home you speak several languages in
your home everyone in the house
explain how this works well my children
are in french school because my husband
is italian but was raised in france as
well so we have italian and french my
mother's serbian
so i speak serbian as well and of course
english
so and i i like to sing serbian songs to
my kids
because they're really cute and i grew
up on them so you actually grew up
on you grew up speaking uh in in the
serbian language yes and singing serbian
songs
in your house yes what are they i mean
what's a serbian song i have no idea
well if you're anything like my husband
even though he speaks other languages
the serbian language although beautiful
has a lot of consonants
and well the curse words are
they're not as short as ours like the
language has more of an emotional
component so everything is
a little uh more descriptive deeper
more specific what do you mean the curse
words are like for example we know what
our curse words are we don't really have
to go into it
and either rattle them off no
yeah you know we know what our curse
words are you know fu
that kind of thing right what's the
serbian what's the translation for a
serbian
curse word well i mean for that it would
it would be some that
literal translation would be something
deeper like you know you're not worthy
go back inside your mama's
hoo-ha you know or something really hard
it's like horrible it's just deeper
go back up in there well here's another
one
okay here's another one um if let's say
your boyfriend cheated on you and said
instead of saying go to hell you would
say you know uh
the book that dobio uh
and you would say like cleveland which
literally means
i hope you get fungus on your balls
beautiful language
[Applause]
there's a lot of those two because i had
a greek friend and he used to say like
there was one i can't remember what it
was but it was
i f the vessel in which you were
baptized
really like harsh really harsh do you
speak now you said your kids from
french school do you speak french you
know i'm learning i'm learning do you
speak french
i no i really don't i speak some spanish
no i i don't but i think you can get by
i get by whenever i'm in france i'm like
oh
i just do that yeah
and i try to do that i don't get away
with that i don't get away with it
because they understand now so my
daughter goes
you know let's speak french so my mommy
doesn't understand oh that's bad you
don't want your kids knowing a language
that you don't know and
i'm having a hard time with it i have a
hard time with the r's
because it's a whole phlegm thing in
france yeah you have to kind of
channel your phlegm often they are just
spitting at us
don't confuse that they're really like
park can you say like in
we say park they say poc
poc yeah disgusting
i think it's very flummy i can't i can't
do it